I I'm always a little leery of trying to
to look into the future I don't think
anybody does a good job of it and least
of all myself however we're we're here
at the long now and we're thinking about
the future so there are a few informed
guesses that I can make now it's easy
when you talk about viruses in the
future to get kind of crazy you know the
many science fiction movies have been
made like this when you see that sort of
stuff you say oh my god you know we're
gonna get some incredible viral strain
it's gonna make us all blow up and
dissolve and spray all over other people
and I don't I don't buy that I don't
think so I mean I don't think that the
disease's we're gonna be worrying about
it going to be things like Ebola I just
don't I think they're gonna we're gonna
be worried about a replay of 1918 where
50 million people died billions of
people actually got infected with this
this particular strain of flu
quote-unquote only 50 million people
died it was able to be so devastating
because it could spread so easily and
part of that meant that it wasn't
totally fatal it wasn't it wasn't
science fictiony it was just horrifying
and so that you ended up with this
relatively small fraction of people who
were infected who died but still because
it infected such a huge part of the
planet the death toll was astonishing
[Music]